die menschheit lebt gerne in münchen
das haus in dem er zur miete wohnt wurde
zum jahreswechsel 2016/17 verkauft doch
zuvor hatte der eigentümer alle
mietwohnungen in eigentumswohnungen
umgewandelt sowie handelnder mensch um
den geht es da nicht da geht es ganz
klar um den profit im kaufvertrag ist
vereinbart für jede wohnung die der
verkäufer dem neuen eigentümer
unvermietet überlässt bekommt er 125.000
euro mehr ein geschäft auf kosten der
mieter
ich bin ich weiß ich bekomme 125000 euro
mehr für die wohnung wenn eine wohnung
leer ist dann schaue ich natürlich dass
ich das leer machen mehreren mietern bot
der verkäufer geld an wenn sie ausziehen
allerdings nur zwischen 5000 und
geschätzt 40.000 euro
tillmann scheich bekam das angebot seine
wohnung selbst zu kaufen wurde mir
telefonisch angeboten quadratmeterpreis
von 13.500 euro und renoviert welcher
mieter soll sich das leisten können
überhaupt das geht ja überhaupt nicht es
ist fernab von jeglicher vorstellungen
zimmern scheich lehnte dankend ab und
blieb meter nun fordert der neue
eigentümer eine höhere miete 15 prozent
unzählige mietwohnungen werden in
deutschland jährlich in eigentum
umgewandelt
allein in berlin waren es zwischen 2011
und 2019 rund 140.000 wohnungen
das will die bundesregierung in zukunft
erschweren wo bezahlbarer wohnraum knapp
ist soll eine umwandlung nur noch
erlaubt sein wenn eine immobilie vererbt
wurde
familienangehörige einziehen ein verbot
für den eigentümer wirtschaftlich
unzumutbar ist oder die eigentümer die
wohnungen an mindestens zwei drittel der
mieter verkaufen
der zuständige bundesbauminister betonte
vor wenigen tagen die bundesregierung
habe die brisanz der lage erkannt
wohnraum ich kann es nicht oft genug
sagen ist die soziale frage unserer zeit
unterstützung von der spd bernhard
daldrup baupolitischer sprecher der
bundestagsfraktion sieht vor allem
mieter in großen städten unter druck
durch die umwandlungen entstehen
verdrängungsprozesse die wir nicht
wollen sondern wir wollen mieterinnen
und mieter vor der umwandlung ihres
zuhauses in einer eigentumswohnung die
automatisch stand dazu führt dass sie
verdrängt werden können schützen
doch der bau und mieten experte der cdu
bundestagsfraktion jan marco luczak
stellt sich gegen das neue gesetz die
umwandlung von miet in
eigentumswohnungen soll weiterhin ohne
einschränkungen möglich sein
vier von fünf deutschen wollen in die
eigenen vier wände
das gilt auch für viele mieter die ja im
falle der umwandlung tatsächlich auch
ein vorkaufsrecht haben sie könnten ja
ihre wohnung kaufen und ich glaube
deswegen müssen wir als politik alles
daransetzen mehr menschen diesen traum
vom eigenheim zu ermöglichen und
deswegen ist dieses umfangs verbot so
kontraproduktiv weil es am ende genau
das verhindert das beste indiz dafür
dass dieses argument nicht stimmt ist
die wirklichkeit und die wirklichkeit
ich nehme das beispiel berlin
hier gibt es 64 milieus gebiete mit
ungefähr 900 tausend menschen in berlin
gibt es die nachricht dass ungefähr ein
prozent der von umwandlung betroffenen
menschen sich eine wohnung haben kaufen
können auch fällt doris koch bleibt der
traum vom eigenen heim ein traum
sie lebt zur miete denn in berlin-mitte
kann sie sich keine eigentumswohnung
leisten viel zu teuer das haus in dem
sie lebt wurde vor drei jahren verkauft
ihre 60 quadratmeter wohnung in eigentum
umgewandelt
mir wurde die wohnung angeboten hier zu
einem vorzugspreis von 300.000 für mich
ist dieser preis absolut überhöht also
ich kann mir so eine wohnung so nicht
leisten durch es koch hat sich deshalb
mit anderen bewohnern ihres hauses einer
initiative angeschlossen hashtag 200
häuser mieter wehren sich gegen
verdrängung durch kapitalstark der
investoren
es gibt erfolge aber nicht so viele muss
man dazu sagen also die übermacht dieser
umwandler firmen ist schon ziemlich
ziemlich massiv
umfragen zeigen viele menschen können
sich wohneigentum schlicht nicht leisten
68 prozent derer die gerne eine
immobilie kaufen würden sagen sie hätten
zu wenig eigenkapital 42 prozent geben
an die monatlichen kosten für zins und
tilgung seien zu hoch jan marco luczak
von der cdu ficht das nicht an
wer nicht kaufen kann oder will habe als
mieter nichts zu befürchten
wir haben in deutschland wahrscheinlich
das beste mietrecht was ganz europa gibt
und das gilt gerade auch im falle der
umwandlung der kündigungsschutz etwa vor
eigenbedarf der sind nicht etwa im falle
einer umwandlung sondern er wird sogar
erhöht in berlin zum beispiel ist es so
dass man zehn jahre absolut für eine
eigenbedarfskündigung geschützt wird
lukas siebenkotten vom deutschen
mieterbund hat da ganz andere
erfahrungen nicht selten tauschen neue
eigentümer vor dass sie in die wohnung
selbst einziehen wollen und kündigen
wir haben leider ja viele fälle bei
denen wir im nachhinein feststellen dass
die eigenbedarfskündigung getürkt war
das heißt dass man eigentlich nur den
mieter loswerden wollte und das dann
einen ganz anderen zahlungskräftigeren
mieter vermietet und das große problem
ist man kommt ja nicht wieder zurück ich
wenn der eine darin wohnt und der andere
ist schon draußen kann er allenfalls
noch schadenersatz verlangen
wie sagte noch der bundesbauminister von
der union wohnraum ich kann es nicht oft
genug sagen ist die soziale frage
unserer zeit seine parteifreunde in der
fraktion wollen seehofers gesetz zum
schutz der mieter am liebsten kippen
die spd warnt den koalitionspartner
deswegen kann ich nur dringend
appellieren dass die cdu ihre internen
probleme
loest und dass sie sich vor allen dingen
nicht alleine von wenigen politikern
leiten lässt
von denen man nicht immer den eindruck
hat dass sie sozusagen frei von
lobbyismus sind bei tim anzeichen
münchen hat der neue eigentümer die
fassade renoviert viele mieter zogen
entnervt aus die leer stehenden
wohnungen werden saniert die mannschaft
lebt seit mehr als zwei jahren auf einer
baustelle für was ist jetzt eigentlich
so eine immobilie da ist es für
ökonomischen wert zu steigern oder ist
zum wohnen gedacht eigentlich in berlin
weist doris koch nicht wie es bei ihr
weitergeht
der eigentümer saniert das haus und
bietet die wohnungen zum verkauf an
viele mieter sind bereits ausgezogen ich
rechne damit dass mit irgendwelchen
mitteln versucht wird mich aus der
wohnung zu bringen also ich nehme an
dass ich keine für mich bezahlbare
wohnung in berlin mehr finde